[Musik]
hochspannung bei der us-wahl
herausforderer beiden gewinnt weitere
staaten präsident ramp setzt auf
juristische hilfe hohe terrorgefahr nach
den anschlägen in wien und nizza warnt
die bundesregierung vor islamisten in
deutschland höchste zahl neuer
ansteckungen knapp 20.000 corona fälle
binnen 24 stunden
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend seien sie
willkommen bei den heute nachrichten an
diesem donnerstag der uns weiter in atem
hält was die usa betrifft sportlich geht
es ein wenig später mit katja stresow zu
ich grüße sie schön und nahm es bleibt
aufregend und denkbar knapp das rennen
zwischen trump und beiden auch wenn der
herausforderer im vorteil scheint je
mehr briefwahlstimmen ausgezählt werden
zwei tage nach der wahl hat joe biden
reale chancen auf den sieg den aber will
präsident trump auf keinen fall
anerkennen wie er schon früh angekündigt
hat er setzt auf die hilfe der gerichte
in den bundesstaaten wisconsin und
michigan liegt beiden uneinholbar vorn
er kommt damit auf 253 der 270
benötigten wahlleute trump hat
inzwischen 214
jetzt kommt es auf die restlichen
bundesstaaten pennsylvania nord carolina
georgia nevada arizona und alaska an
rechnerisch könnten beide noch gewinnen
britta jäger in einem diner in phoenix
arizona liegen die nerven blank
noch ist unklar wer in dem bundesstaat
das rennen macht hier haben sie trump
gewählt und glauben wie der präsident
dass bei der wahl nicht alles mit
rechten dingen zugeht
ich mache mir sorgen bin aber weiter
optimistisch wir werden sehen
und wir wissen alle dass ein kämpfer wir
können hier nach gucken ob unsere stimme
gezählt worden ist und meine stimme ist
abgelehnt worden das ist das problem
darum denken wir dass den amerikanern
die wahl gestohlen wird eine ungültige
stimme vielleicht auch weil sie selbst
einen fehler gemacht hat in arizona wird
noch ausgezählt genauso wie in nevada in
den bundesstaaten liegt herausforderer
beiden knapp vorn
sollte er sie beide holen würde das für
den demokraten reichen um ins weiße haus
einzuziehen
mit der niederlage vor augen wütet trump
auf twitter stoppt die weitere
auszählung fordert er in großbuchstaben
seine an
henger wie hier in michigan tun es ihm
gleich fordern die wahlhelfer wütend auf
das zählen einzustellen
auch in georgia wird noch gezählt trump
liegt hier knapp vorn und offizielle
sehen sich genötigt ihre wahlhelfer in
schutz zu nehmen
sie denken an die stimme jeder person
hier und im ganzen land diese leute sind
nicht in wahlfälschung oder in waal
unterdrückung involviert in mehreren
teilen des landes protest tram fans und
der beiden anhänger auf der straße
entlädt sich spannung über die frage wer
hier in den nächsten jahren rechtmäßig
regieren darf präsidentschaftskandidat
beiden hat vor allem im schlüsselstaat
pennsylvania seinen rückstand auf krampf
verkürzt von mehr als zehn
prozentpunkten am wahltag auf momentan
etwas weniger als 2 prozentpunkte
das liegt daran in pennsylvania wurden
zunächst die stimmen vom wahltag gezählt
und die vielen mehrheitlich für trump
aus zehntausende briefwähler und bürger
die vor dem wahltag ihre stimme abgaben
stimmten aber für beiden ihre stimmen
werden jetzt ausgezählt elmar theveßen
im gerichtsgebäude von montur counties
demokratie mühsamer kleinstarbeit aber
sie funktioniert tadellos die
briefwahlstimmen werden vorsichtig
geöffnet penibel sortiert und dann
eingescannt begonnen haben sie erst am
tag nach der wahl um jeden fehler aus
stress zu vermeiden
wir stellen sicher dass die zählung von
hier komplett und akkurat ist 100%
akkurat hier wo die meisten trump wählen
erfährt jede stimme exakt die gleiche
sorgfalt wie hier in philadelphia wo vor
allem joe biden stimmen 1 fährt weil es
insgesamt so viele sind auch hier in
pittsburgh lagern noch über 150000
briefwahlstimmen dauert es und weil mehr
demokraten per brief wählen als
republikaner verkürzt jeder
zwischenstand in pennsylvania den
vorsprung von dolmetschern
der schickt deshalb seinen sohn und
seinen persönlichen anwalt die sollen
die auszählung per klage stoppen weil
die demo
warten angeblich immer neue stimmen für
die beiden finden wir gewinnen
pennsylvania aber sie wollen uns
betrügen weil es ja einziger weg zum
sieg ist das neue stimmen kistenweise
irgendwo auftauchen sei abwegig mal die
regierung des bundesstaates
das könnte in pennsylvania nicht
passieren man findet hier keine stimmen
die sind registriert und es sind
vertreter von jeder partei und jedem
kandidaten zugelassen im raum menschen
in philadelphia fürchten dass trump den
demokratischen prozess untergraben
könnte einmal wurde heute die auszählung
sogar kurzzeitig gestoppt
da fragen wir doch gleich mal nach bei
unserer korrespondentin in washington
ines trams was hat das zu bedeuten wenn
jetzt die auszählung vorübergehend
gestoppt wird genau richtig die
auszählung in pennsylvania ist heute für
eine knappe stunde gestoppt worden und
zwar auf antrag der demokraten was war
passiert das team das wahlkampf team
rund um präsident trump hatte
gerichtlich erwirkt dass ihre wahlkampf
ihre wahlbeobachter
zum einen in die aus zehn stationen
hinein dürfen und auch näher an den
eigentlichen aus ziel vorgang heran
dürfen das wiederum wollten die
demokraten nicht akzeptieren haben
versucht ihrerseits dagegen vorzugehen
deswegen wurde der aus ziel vorgang in
pennsylvania für eine stunde gestoppt
aber die demokraten mussten sich
geschlagen geben
wir hören die auszählung läuft wieder
und zwar mit den wahlbeobachtern von dem
team trump vor ort trump wollte ja von
anfang an einen wahlsieg beiden
juristisch anfechten
gibt es denn tatsächlich irgendwelche
hinweise auf wahlbetrug
nein es gibt keine hinweise keine belege
für systematischen wahlbetrug in den
staaten die trump der zeit angeht sie
sprechen zwar von wahlbetrug trump und
seine leute aber sie haben bislang keine
belege dafür vorgelegt auch die
wahlbeobachter der osze haben bislang
keine hinweise auf wahlbetrug finden
können und zwar weder für den wahltag
selber noch für die tage zuvor
vielen dank für diesen informationen
lässt rahmens aus washington der us wahl
krimi geht weiter dazu sendet das zdf
auch heute ein spezial gleich im
anschluss auch die zdf heute app hält
sie auf dem laufenden
dort gibt es aktuelle zwischenstände zur
auszählung und viele weitere
informationen wenn ein eu-land künftig
gegen rechtsstaatlichkeit verstößt
könnte das teuer werden
kommission und europaparlament haben
sich darauf geeinigt in diesem fall
gelder massiv zu kürzen
etwa wenn regierungen die justiz
beeinflussen vor allem ungarn und polen
wird das immer wieder vorgeworfen die
beiden länder drohen nun den eigenen
haushalt zu blockieren sollte der
rechtsstaats mechanismus tatsächlich
eingeführt werden
nach den terrorangriffen in österreich
und frankreich sind die deutschen
sicherheitsbehörden alarmiert auch bei
uns könne es jederzeit wieder einen
islamistischen anschlag geben warnt der
verfassungsschutz in deutschland werden
zurzeit 620 islamistische gefährder
beobachtet weil die behörden ihnen einen
anschlag zu trauern mit der terrorgefahr
in europa hat sich heute der bundestag
beschäftigt aus berlin berichtet was
bohnsack ein mord in dresden eine
enthauptung in paris vier tote bei
anschlag in wien islamistischer
terrorist eine akute gefahr für europa
und damit auch für deutschland
die gefährdungslage bei uns im lande ist
hoch
das heißt
für die allgemeinheit übersetzt ohne
dass wir angst machen wir bescheiden die
realität mit anschlägen muss auch bei
uns jederzeit gerechnet werden man müsse
islamistischen terrorismus bekämpfen
nicht den islam
darin sind sich die parteien genauso
einig wie in der forderung die
sicherheitsbehörden zu stärken in
unserem föderalen staat teilen sich die
sicherheitsbehörden die aufgaben
deswegen ist eine enge kooperation und
abstimmung zwischen den
sicherheitsbehörden entscheidend für den
erfolg beim kampf gegen den terror
und doch es war mangelnde kooperation
der sicherheitsbehörden die den anschlag
auf dem berliner breitscheidplatz vor
vier jahren ermöglicht hatte zugeben
will dass niemand auch nicht vor dem
untersuchungsausschuss des bundestags
es ging ganz offensichtlich nach dem
anschlag nicht nur darum den anschlag
aufzuklären mögliche hintermänner zu
verfolgen sondern die schuld für den
anschlag auf andere bundesbehörden
abzuschieben
zweifel gibt es auch an der
internationalen zusammenarbeit
es gibt immer noch keine europaweit
einheitliche definition des gefährder
begriffs also auch hier müssen wir davon
ausgehen dass personen in
unterschiedlichen ländern auf
unterschiedliche art und weise
priorisiert überwacht und auch behandelt
werden um den islamistischen terrorismus
erfolgreich zu bekämpfen bleibt offenbar
noch einiges zu tun
in wien fordert die regierung mehr
befugnisse für die sicherheitskräfte im
anti-terror-kampf kanzler kurz sagte im
österreichischen parlament geheimdienste
polizei und justiz hätten nicht immer
die rechtlichen mittel gefährder zu
überwachen
nach dem anschlag mit vier todesopfern
gibt es in österreich kritik an den
behörden weil der täter als sympathisant
bekannt und zeitweilig inhaftiert war
jetzt zum thema corona da meldet das
robert koch institut einen neuen
höchstwert bei den neuinfektionen
demnach wurden in deutschland binnen 24
stunden 19.990 neue ansteckungen
registriert wie sich corona bei uns
ausbreitet zeigt auch der steigende
ein teil der positivtests im vergangenen
monat hat er sich in etwa verdreifacht
auf jetzt knapp 7,3 prozent mit den
infektionen steigt auch die zahl der
patienten die ins krankenhaus kommen
wer einen schweren krankheitsverlauf hat
muss durchschnittlich 16 tage auf der
insel der intensivstation behandelt
werden bis jetzt durch neue
behandlungsmethoden könnte sich das aber
ändern
mehr dazu von melanie haack vier
intensivstationen hat die uniklinik jena
diese haben sie freigeräumt für die
schweren corona fälle fünf von acht
betten sind belegt die zahlen steigen
wieder
aber auch das wissen über die behandlung
mit dem konsequenten einsatz von
blutverdünnenden mitteln und mit
entzündungshemmenden mitteln aber
deutlich bessere erfolge die patienten
sind nicht mehr so lange auf der
intensivstation
nebenan auf der infektionsstation liegen
20 corona patienten die weniger schweren
fälle mathias pletz ist der chef
infektiologe seit monaten erforscht er
das sams kopf 2 virus auch anhand der
neustadt studie
neustadt ein ort in thüringen der im
frühjahr zwei wochen unter quarantäne
stand eine antikörper studie brachte
jetzt neue erkenntnisse und eine
vermutung was die impfung angeht wird es
wahrscheinlich so sein dass eine
einmalige impfung keinen dauerhaften
schutz bietet sie wird sicherlich ein
schutz für mehrere monate vielleicht
auch für ein jahr oder zwei jahre bieten
aber keinen dauerhaften schutz auf der
intensivstation sind sie erstmal
ausgestattet die geräte reichen aber das
pflegepersonal wird knapp und was wenn
sie sich anstecken und ausfallen
die beatmungspatienten brauchen eins zu
eins pflege rund um die uhr der tage
sehr angespannt unter anderem auch was
die pflege besetzung hat angeht trotzdem
stellen wir uns den herausforderungen
stand jetzt sind an der uniklinik jena
mehr als doppelt so viele corona
patienten in behandlung wie zu
spitzenzeiten im frühjahr stand jetzt
die winter monate kommen noch
nach großbritannien das wie kaum ein
zweites land in europa mit steigenden
corona zahlen kämpft zuletzt gab es
25.000 neuinfektionen allein gestern
sind fast 500 menschen an cupid 19
gestorben
in anderen landesteilen gibt es bereits
länger beschränkungen seit mitternacht
ist auch in england das öffentliche
leben massiv heruntergefahren
den letzten abend nutzten noch mal viele
um ausgelassen zu feiern
andreas stamm berichtet das wetter und
die allgemeine stimmung finden
zueinander am tag an dem england zum
zweiten mal die läden unten lässt papst
restaurants sind zu private treffen tabu
wochenlang erklärte die regierung es
gehe ohne zweiten lockdown hat corona
strategien ausprobiert verworfen was das
heißt weiß ließ er klaut die nach
monatelanger planung in neun tagen
heiraten wollte 150 gäste sollten es
werden im ersten lockdown mussten die
auf 60 runter bei der nächsten änderung
durften noch 15 nun fällt die hochzeit
ganz ins wasser
die in welle 1 am härtesten getroffene
wirtschaft in europa kam gerade wieder
auf die beine
in dieser brauerei werden sie nun erneut
alles an tiere verfüttert
hopfen und malz verloren als es
verkündet wurde haben wir nicht gedacht
oh india die an diesem punkt machen wir
schon denn diesmal könnte der betrieb
das nicht überstehen
wie düster die lage ist lange wollte die
regierung ein großzügiges
lohnfortzahlung programm nicht
verlängern nun geht es weiter bis märz
die vierte änderung des rettungsplans in
sechs wochen
wir haben damit ein noch nie dagewesenes
wirtschaftliches hilfsprogramm
ausgesetzt als die löhne und jobs von
millionen menschen schützt ich sehe
licht am ende des tunnels schulen und
universitäten bleiben diesmal offen
ansonsten heißt es wieder nur aus für
sport zum arztbesuch oder einkauf nur in
essenziellen geschäften die lehre ist
zurück vier wochen so der plan oder doch
länger denn außer dem premier sehen nur
wenige ein lichtblick sondern eher trübe
aussichten
der kinderwunsch eines paares er kann
problematisch sein wenn vater oder
mutter eine erbkrankheit haben helfen
kann die präimplantationsdiagnostik also
die untersuchung des embryos vor dem
einsetzen in die gebärmutter
bisher wurde das in deutschland nur
genehmigt wenn die krankheit regelmäßig
schon im kindesalter ausbricht das
bundesverwaltungsgericht hat den
spielraum jetzt erwartet günther neu
fahrradfahren geht nur noch gemeinsam
sie allein schafft es nicht mehr
der grund eine unheilbare erbkrankheit
fortschreitende muskelschwäche vor 13
jahren wussten sie noch nichts davon
sie bekamen ein baby bei denen die
krankheit gleich ausbrach die kleine
julia wurde nur acht wochen alt er
musste sofort beraten und behandelt
werden und versorgt werden und nach zwei
monaten mussten wir uns schon von ihr
verabschieden
robert und judith brede busch kanten ihr
risiko nicht an dass das paar das nun
vor gericht zog es möchte nicht vor die
kamera
hier ist die erkrankung des mannes
bekannt und die gehen diagnose sagt mit
fünfzigprozentiger wahrscheinlichkeit
würde es auch das kind treffen
vermutlich erst im erwachsenenalter das
paar beantragte eine
präimplantationsdiagnostik
dabei werden eizellen außerhalb des
körpers befruchtet nach ein paar tagen
erkennt man welche embryo die krankheit
geerbt hat und welcher nicht der
unbelasteten embryo wird der frau
eingesetzt
der belastete weggeworfen erlaubt war
das bisher nur bei erbkrankheiten die
immer schon im kindesalter ausbrechen
deshalb hatte das paar keine genehmigung
erhalten dagegen klagte es und bekam
recht damit hat das gericht die
möglichkeiten erweitert
präimplantationsdiagnostik kann jetzt
auch erlaubt werden bei erbkrankheiten
die meist erst im erwachsenenalter
auftreten
robert und judith brede bush hatten
diese chance nicht
ihnen bleibt nur die erinnerung an die
acht wochen mit ihrem baby ja vater
schnitt jetzt zum sport und zur fußball
champions league
und da waren ja auch gestern haben die
beiden deutschen mann
haften erfolgreich katja in der tat denn
dortmund gewannen beim belgischen
meister fc brügge mit 3 zu 0 und rb
leipzig trainer julia nagelsmann sagte
nach dem spiel gegen paris st germain
gut zugehört und gut gemacht die buben
denn seine buben drehten einen 0 1
rückstand zu einem 2 1-sieg ein fehlpass
von ohb amerikaner gleich in der vierten
minute macht die aufgabe gegen den
champions-league-finalisten noch
schwieriger auch ohne die stars papier
und nema geht paris in führung die maria
ist weiblich trupp amerikaners einziges
missgeschick handspiel und elfmeter die
maria tritt an polaski hält die wende im
spiel
der thüringer schwede forsberg
ausgangspunkt das eins zu eins noch vor
der pause durch einen früheren pse
spieler in kumo der verdiente ausgleich
für die nagelsmann 11 als leipzig einen
handelfmeter bekommt passt forsberg
nicht der siegtreffer
revanche geglückt für das letzte
champions league halbfinale
thomas tuchel muss noch zwei
platzverweise für seine mannschaft
hinnehmen bleibt sich aber dank vorstand
nun punktgleich hinter manunited
gruppenzweiter im ersten
qualifikationsspiel zur handball wm 2022
hat deutschland mit 25 22 gegen bosnien
herzegowina gewonnen glücklich denn erst
mitte der zweiten halbzeit schaffte das
team von trainer alfred gislason die
wende und ging erstmals in führung
so mühsam hatte er sich seine premiere
sicher nicht vorgestellt habe ich hinter
mir das ist nicht ganz in die hose
gegangen aber wir haben viel zu viel zu
tun
die deutsche mannschaft fand in
düsseldorf lange nicht ins spiel das lag
an der guten verteidigung der wegen
corona stark dezimierten bosnier ihrem
überragenden torwart und am hohen tempo
dass deutschland kaum mitgehen konnte
vier tore rückstand zur pause danach war
geht's lasst uns team die ausgewechselt
bessere abwehr mehr biss mehr sicherheit
julius kühn knapp neun minuten nach
wiederanpfiff mit der ersten führung von
nun an gaben sie das heft nicht mehr aus
der hand und zeigten ihr ganzes
potenzial am ende ein deutliches 25 zu
21 das aber viel luft nach oben ist
nächste chance und am sonntag gegen
island wieder live im zdf
danke katja das herbstwetter bleibt
ruhig mal mit nebel mal mit wolken und
oft mit sehr viel sonne mir dazu gleich
von katja schäfer
das war es von uns schön dass sie dabei
waren morgen erwartet sie hier an dieser
stelle barbara hahlweg vielleicht gibt
es dann ja auch einen neuen präsidenten
und mit dem spezial zur us wahl geht es
hier auch gleich weiter wir wünschen
ihnen noch einen angenehmen abend
tschüss
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren
einige stunden brauchte die sonne und
diese nebelfelder hier am rhein an der
mosel und der aa aufzulösen dann aber
strahlte die sonne vom saarland bis nach
sachsen dichter waren die wolken im
norden und dem süden und das bleibt auch
in der nacht so in der mitte aber bildet
sich zum teil wie der dichter nebel mit
geringen sichtweiten und da sinken die
temperaturen auf null bis minus fünf
grad es gibt also verbreitet bodenfrost
es kann auch gefährlich glatt seien auf
den straßen und auf den gehwegen bilder
bleibt die nacht an den alpen und in
norddeutschland bei 10 bis 4 grad morgen
liegen die höchsttemperaturen zwischen 7
grad an den alpen und 14 grad in
schleswig-holstein das wetter ist
ähnlich wie heute in norddeutschland
sind die wolken etwas dichter lassen
aber mehr platz für die sonne auch die
wolken an den alpen werden weniger und
dazwischen scheint häufig die sonne
und mit diesen ruhigen zu lieben eigenen
hochdruckwetter geht es auch in den
nächsten tagen weiter schönen abend noch